the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so I'd like to do a quick two or three
minute review of the stuff we did last
time to get you back into where we were
we were talking about different types of
technologies that use the stuff field
the youth learning in 2201 everything
ranging from nuclear reactors for
producing power and the Cherenkov
radiation that tells you well that the
beta particles are moving faster than
the speed of light in water is a neat
thing - I've actually been to this
reactor at Idaho - the spent fuel pool
even the spent fuel once it comes out of
the reactor is still giving off betas
and still giving off Cherenkov radiation
and you can tell how long it's been out
of the reactor by how dim the glow gets
which is pretty cool so you can tell how
all the fuel assembly is by the blue
glow so remember I told you guys if
someone says oh your nuclear do you glow
green you could be like no it's blue
that's the right way of things we talked
about fusion energy and got into some of
the nuclear reactions involved in fusion
energy and I'll be teaching you more
about these today
why fission and fusion work it all has
to do with the stability and binding
energy of the nuclei involved and
that'll be the main topic for today is
excess mass binding energy nuclear
stability we looked at medical uses of
radiation from implanting radioactive
seeds of called brachytherapy seeds in
certain places to destroy tumors to
imaging to x-ray therapy to proton
therapy using accelerators or cyclotrons
to accelerate protons and send them into
people if you remember last time we ran
the srem code of the stopping range of
ions and matter and actually showed that
protons all stop at a certain distance
in tissue depending on their energy and
what you're sending them into let's see
talked about brachytherapy we talked
about radiotracers and this is going to
be one of the other main topics for
today is these decay diagrams and
figuring out not only what products are
made but what energy levels - the nuclei
have and how do you calculate the energy
of the radioactive decay products and
the recoil nuclei which do take away
some of the energy we talked about one
way to get rich if you guys can figure
out one of the ways to solve this Molly
99 shortage right now it's mostly
and reactors the future has got to be
accelerators or some sort of switchable
device where you don't need to construct
a reactor to make these medical isotopes
for imaging and tracers and such and
finally we got all the way up to space
applications shielding crazy different
types of shielding like electromagnetic
shielding to protect from high-energy
protons all the way to radio thermal
generators which use alpha decay to
produce a constant amount of energy on
the order of 1 to 200 watts for like a
hundred years and finally to a different
configuration of nuclear reactors where
you can design them to produce thrust
not necessarily electricity and that's
where we stopped on Friday so let's move
on to one of the things I'd alluded to
earlier which is semiconductor
processing this is actually a diagram
from the MIT reactor because we have
this beam port here
has anyone got to see the silicon beam
port at the MIT reactor about seven
eight okay about how for you for those
who have and who here has not had a
nuclear reactor tour oh man okay well
you'll get one when you get to control
the thing in early October so you
actually get to go down to the control
room and see the rest of what's going on
so make sure to ask them show us the
beam port for silicate ingots and I
think I already told you the story about
the pour UROP who held the ingots up to
their chest getting about ten months of
dose which is not dangerous but it meant
that for ten months they can have no
radiation exposure and they had to
answer the phone so that's how we ensure
safety around here there's other ones
that applications that you're probably
carrying around in your pocket you can
use the fact that charge particles have
very finite ranges and matter to
separate little bits of that matter from
other things so this is actually how
single crystal sapphires can be
separated in little slivers for
protective phone covers because
sapphires one of the most the hardest of
the most scratch resistant materials
there is single crystal sapphire is
exceptionally strong and optically
transparent and expensive I know that
because on one of our experiments we use
a single crystal sapphire window to see
into reactor conditions at like 150
atmospheres
and 350 degrees Celsius and pretty
corrosive chemistry so you want to use
as little as possible so you can use a
big expensive accelerator to limit the
amount of sapphire that you use and this
is actually done here in Boston there's
a facility not far from here that uses
an accelerator and this is their super
detailed diagram of what the radiation
looks like yeah whatever but what they
do is they take they accelerate protons
they send them through bending magnets
to steer that beam path and then they
send them into a large piece of single
crystal sapphire which is exceptionally
expensive to make and they can actually
lift off a thin sliver with micron
precision the reason for that is the
same reason that we showed with that
srem code if you to have this exact
energy of protons going into well-known
matter you know what its range is going
to be with an uncertainty or so of about
a micron so you can have things that
come out thin uniformly and thick and
smooth right away
there's some other really wacky products
like if anyone heard of these beta
voltaic batteries no they rely on beta
decay or the direct capture and
electricity generation from a radiation
source like radioactive tritium so in
this little chip is about two Curie's
worth of tritium you guys will learn in
oh about a week how to go from activity
and Curie's into mass or something like
that and so this chip actually contains
a lot of radioactive tritium that
directly creates electricity so you can
hook into that chip and produce nano
watts for years so it's one of these
batteries that lasts well as long as a
couple half-lives of the isotope that's
inside now there's a trade-off here the
shorter the half-life the more active a
given isotope will be for the same
number of atoms but the shorter it will
last so you can have higher power for
lower time or lower pi or Howard time
it's the classic energy trade-off works
the same way with irradiation and so now
I wanted to get into some of the more
technical stuff where we'll be talking
about nuclear mass and stability and
this is where the nuclear stuff really
begins in 2201 first I want to make sure
that we all agree on
so I'll be writing isotopes in this sort
of fashion or we referred to a as the
atomic mass or just the total number of
nucleons this is not the exact mass of a
nucleus it just refers to the sum of the
protons and neutrons in the nucleus
itself and a lot of what we'll be
talking about today is the difference
between this nice integer mass number
and the actual mass of the nucleus and
that difference is given by the binding
energy or the excess mass which are
directly related Z is just referred to
as the atomic number or the number of
protons it's what makes the element what
it is which makes the name kind of
redundant but it's so humans learn by
association it's easier to remember
element names or symbols than which
element is which just by the number of
protons so a lot of times we'll use the
name or at least the symbol just so we
know what's going on and anything up
here is some sort of a charge I do want
to warn you guys of the dreaded multiple
symbol use or multiple use of symbols
I'll try to stick for a lowercase Q will
be charged an uppercase Q is going to
refer to the Q value or the energy
consumed or released by a nuclear
reaction so they're both Q's but we're
gonna keep one upper and lowercase and
like we mentioned before let's say we
were to write a typical nuclear reaction
like the capture of neutrons by boron to
produce lithium seven helium four better
known as an alpha particle and some
amount of energy there's two places
where we actually use this reaction one
of them is as control rods Alana
reactors use boron for carbide or this
compound B for C which is conveniently
solid fairly dense and contains a whole
lot of boron in one place specifically
enriched in boron 10 because boron 10
has a high cross-section or probability
for Neutron capture and the other one is
in what's called boron Neutron capture
therapy if I discuss this with you guys
already BNCT
good because that's what we'll be
talking about for a few slides and to
write this whole reaction is the same
thing as writing this shorthand nuclear
reaction so this is often how you see
them in the reading and in papers
because it's shorter to do that but it's
the
exact same thing so I have a couple
questions for you guys then I have this
extra queue here where does that queue
actually go so let's say boron and
neutron absorb it produces two nuclei
with different binding energies what
happens to the excess energy created
from the conversion of mass to energy
yeah Alex yep and heat more specifically
kinetic energy of the radiation released
and so that kinetic energy is actually
used to our benefit in BNCT or boron
Neutron capture therapy the way this
works once I hit play is you can either
use any sort of source of neutrons
either a reactor or an accelerator
through a lower complex chain of events
like this in this case an accelerator so
you don't need a whole reactor fires a
beam of high-energy protons into a
beryllium target that sound fairly
familiar firing something at beryllium
releasing neutrons like what Chadwick
was doing except he was firing alpha
particles into it this releases neutrons
what they don't have labeled here is
slowing down stuff or probably
hydrogenous material so that the
neutrons slow down to a lower energy and
their probability of capture increases
or their cross-section increases if you
don't know what a cross-section is the
definition is two slides away and the
idea here is that these neutrons then
enter the brain or wherever the tumour
happens to be and we rely on the fact
that tumor cells consume resources much
faster than regular cells especially
neurons which after you're about five
don't tend to grow very much so it's all
downhill by the time you enter
kindergarten and we use that to our
advantage so that the neutrons coming in
will hit the cancer cells which will
preferentially uptake the bohr aidid
compounds leaving most of the normal
cells intact and the difference in dose
can be a factor of five or a factor of
ten so that the cancer gets fried while
doing as little damage as possible that
the remaining brain cells of which we
have fewer and fewer every day so I say
statistically speaking you guys are
probably smarter than me if we go by
number of neurons in your brain because
I think I'm the oldest person in the
room
and so now we can start to explain how
does BNCT work and why did we make the
choices that we did for example they use
30 MeV protons in order to induce these
neutrons so we have a nuclear reaction
that looks something like this we start
off with beryllium 9 plus a proton let's
just call it hydrogen to stick with our
normal notation and becomes well can
someone help me balance this reaction we
know we get a neutron what else is left
no Monica what would you say
even just say number of protons and
neutrons and we'll figure out the symbol
leader sorry oh that's a yep five
protons which means it's boron and
number of neutrons in the nucleus
someone else yeah nine so we have boron
nine not a stable isotope of boron but
doesn't really matter because boron nine
almost immediately decays into an alpha
and an alpha and a hydrogen but this
nuclear reaction right here is what
we'll be studying for a little bit and
they'll also be some amount of energy
and this Q can actually be positive or
negative
no one said there had to be energy
released in a nuclear reaction because
in this case we actually start off with
thirty MeV protons and roughly zero and
maybe beryllium if you want to get
really exact it's on the order of about
0.01 evey which is why we neglect the
kinetic energy of beryllium at room
temperature there are other reactions
that when you fire a proton into them
will produce neutrons such as the
absorption of lithium but can anyone
think of why we'd want to use beryllium
instead of lithium
Kristen what do you think what could be
a bad thing about using lithium you ever
throw it in water okay then I should
show you what happens when you throw it
in water there's a few bad things about
lithium it does this when you throw it
in water it's one of the alkali metals
it's got an awfully low melting point it
reacts with oxygen to produce an oxide
almost instantaneously so if you ever
take a lift the embargo riah part which
you shouldn't but if you watch the video
of somebody else doing it you'll see
that the lithium foil turns black almost
instantly it also has a pretty poor
thermal conductivity and doesn't hold
its structural integrity when it melts
so it's not that good of a target to use
beryllium is pretty cool and that it's
the lightest structural material there
is folks tend to make satellites out of
it because it costs a lot of money to
launch things into space and if you want
something that has a high melting point
and is light and is structural beryllium
is your way to go it also happens to be
a great neutron generator and then why
30 MeV in this case we're going to look
use a table called Janus which I've got
open over here and I just have to clone
my screen so you can see it this is a
resource that I think you guys are going
to be using quite a lot in this course
we have a link to it on the learning
module site and I'm gonna show you how
it works right now so I tend to use the
web version because it works on any
browser or any computer and now you can
start to pick which nuclear reaction
you're looking at and you can get
tabulated cross-sections so I'm gonna
start by zooming all the way out we can
pick our incident particle since in this
case we're looking at the firing of
protons into beryllium I'll pick the
incident proton data right here there's
a lot of different databases with
sometimes conflicting information I tend
to go with the most recent one you can
find and click on cross-sections and
this is again another table of nuclides
anything in green there's data for
anything in gray there isn't so let's go
all the way back to the light nuclei
zoom in
go back down to the light nuclei again
until we find beryllium 9 double-click
on that and let's look for the anything
cross-section and this is a pretty wide
energy scale so you can actually change
your x minimum and maximum so let's
change it to a minimum and maximum I
don't know a maximum of fifty MeV we
don't have to see all of that other
stuff going on fifty MeV and maybe a
minimum of ten if you notice actually
I'll go back to one and I want to point
something out it you can actually get a
good yield of beryllium let's say you
can actually get a good yield of
neutrons by firing protons at beryllium
and lower energies but I noticed there's
this interesting feature right around
there the cross-sections flatter and so
if you want to get an insurer that you
get the right dose you might want to
deal with a flatter cross section or a
flatter probability region so that you
have something more predictable instead
of in a really high slope region but
some of these nuclear reactions actually
take extra energy in order to move
forward and we'll show you another
example pretty quickly let's go back to
our slides here then another question is
how does the boron only get into the
cancer cells like we mentioned before
cancer cells are actively growing which
means they need a very large and active
blood supply and so it's one way for
things to let's say not quite cross the
blood-brain barrier if the cancer cells
are growing and your neurons aren't then
your cancer cells are going to use more
energy take in more sugar which might be
doped with boron or some other compound
doped with boron and that's how you can
get the boron into the cells that you
want and then why was boron selected for
the therapy let's think about that what
happens after the neutron is created and
let's write the next stage of the
reaction and boron Neutron capture
therapy we rely on doping the patient
with boron 10 to release an alpha
particle
and lithium-7
and a gamma-ray so now what we can start
doing is look at the table of nuclides
which I'm going to teach you how to read
now to figure out let's say that this
neutron had an energy of about 0a v and
the boron nucleus had an energy of about
0a v and in the end all this stuff here
has gained or lost some sort of energy Q
and today we're gonna teach you how to
calculate this Q so I'm gonna skip ahead
to how to read the table of nuclides so
there's all this is like the poster
you'll see in every nuclear building
it's kind of what makes us us what
you'll notice is that there's a whole
lot of nuclei at the lower left there
are the light ones at the upper right
there the heavier ones and they're
colored by half-life in general the blue
ones will be stable and the further away
you get from blue the less stable they
get so right away without even delving
deeper what patterns do you guys notice
here yeah Alex yeah there's a whole
section where there's no more blue there
are no stable elements so stability
drops off after a certain point and what
about in the region of stable isotopes
does anybody notice any repeating
patterns here take a look at every other
row there's a bunch of blues and then
one and then a bunch and then one and
then more and then none that must be
technetium so that's the only element
around there that doesn't have any and
then a bunch of Blues so every other row
and in this case it's increasing number
of protons has more or fewer stable
isotopes it turns out that the
even-numbered isotopes have a lot more
stable ones for reasons that we'll get
into pretty soon if you zoom in a little
bit you can see all the different
isotopes so you can select which ones
you want and again if you look really
closely that lets say neon right here
has got a few stable ones sodium has one
magnesium has three
aluminum has one and this pattern
repeats all the way up to the point
where you don't really get any more
stable isotopes if you double click on
one of them you get all the information
that you'll need for the next 3 or so
weeks of the course so in this case I
picked on sulfur 32 one of the stable
isotopes of sulfur so if you notice it
doesn't have any decay mechanisms here
but it does say it's atomic abundance so
you can know how what percentage is
normally found in nature and then
there's a few other quantities that is
going to be the topic of what's going on
here let's start with the atomic mass if
you notice the atomic mass is slightly
less than 32 32 being the mass number or
the total number of protons plus
neutrons in the nucleus the actual mass
is a little lower by that amount right
there the binding energy it might be a
little funny because I've given you a
mass an amu and a binding energy and
kill electron volts I want to remind you
that these are the same thing the
conversion factor you'll be using over
and over again throughout this course
especially on the next P sets is one
atomic mass unit is 930 1.49 mb v c
squared yeah I'm sorry
yeah nevermind put that there so then
again one don't round because we've had
times when folks said oh this is about
931 and when you're off by half an MeV
you could be at a totally different
decay level or get a positive Q when it
should be negative or vice versa and
let's take a quick look here to say if
this atomic mass is thirty one point
nine seven two O 707 amu this is why I
brought a calculator normally I do
mental math but since I told you guys
don't round I can't do eight significant
digits in my head so I'm going to get
that in there
oh seven oh seven if any you guys want
to follow along I encourage you to and
say minus 32 which is the mass number so
in this case we're taking
the actual atomic mass - the actual
amount the mass number in this case is
32 in this case it's 31 point nine seven
two oh seven oh seven and we end up with
minus 0.02 put all the digits here - 9 3
amu if we convert this to MeV times nine
thirty one point four nine we get minus
twenty six point oh one five nine MeV
see this number anywhere on the khari
table right there
that's the excess mass and in this case
we usually give this the symbol Delta
for the excess mass and these are how
these quantities are directly related
the excess mass well actually what does
the excess mass really mean it's the
difference between the actual mass and a
fairly poor approximation of the mass so
the excess mass doesn't really have that
much of a physical connotation but it is
nice because if you know very well the
tabulated atomic number I'm sorry the
yeah the mass number and the excess mass
you can figure out let's see yeah you
can figure out what the real atomic mass
is and I want to switch now to the
actual table of nuclides and show you
one example if you want to very quickly
jump between isotopes you can type them
in right up here and does anyone know
what the gold standard for atomic mass
is and I'll give you a hint it's not
gold yep carbon-12 what do you think the
the excess mass of carbon 12 is going to
be without doing any calculations
exactly zero so if we go to carbon-12
because that is set as the standard the
way atomic masses were done was
carbon-12 weighs exactly 12 amu the
excess mass here is zero and that's why
the atomic
12.0 to as many decimals as we care to
note so is everyone clear on what excess
mass is yep so mass does not actually
equal alright and it's actually on the
my chalk - it's actually down below the
point is that energy is related to mass
by C squared so there are not the same
units but they're directly convertible
yep and so this way you have an e over a
C squared you get an M and there we go I
have the unit's upside down however calm
carbon-12 does not have a zero binding
energy yeah
MeV per C squared yeah yeah that's true
so it's it is funny right the binding
energies give it in ke V and that's
correct and energies and energy and
excess mass it really should say ke V
per C squared because if we're talking
in units of mass it's got to be in m or
using this way you could say M is an
energy per C squared so this to me is a
semantic inconsistency in the table but
you guys will know that a mass is always
going to be in AMU or kilograms or MeV
per C squared and energies will be in
MeV ke V some sort of Eevee usually in
this course the binding energy though
that's that's correct that's in ke V
because that's an actual energy now then
the question is what is the binding
energy actually represent does anyone
remember from Friday or Thursday I can
refresh your memory that's what I'm here
to do the binding energy is as if let's
say we're assembling carbon-12 from its
constituent nucleons there's going to be
12 of them let's say we had six protons
and six neutrons we can calculate the
total mass energy of this ensemble of
nucleons when they're infinitely far
apart from each other and forgive the
low it's not to scale but they are
infinitely far apart from each other and
we can say that let's say there's Z
number of protons so we'll say the
binding energy is the number of protons
times the mass of a proton plus the
number of neutrons a minus C times the
mass of a neutron minus the energy of
the assembled carbon-12 nucleus
so there's actually a measurable
difference in mass between six protons
and six neutrons and the actual mass of
a nucleus with atomic number a and I'm
sorry with atomic number Z and mass
number a C squared so is everyone clear
on how we arrived at this formula it's
effectively the energy released when you
take the individual nucleons assemble
the nucleus you don't have as much mass
as when you start it or in some cases
you might have a little more mass than
when you started
if things are particularly unstable and
you can use the excess mass and binding
energies and relative amounts to see is
a nucleus going to be stable for example
let's look at iron 55 I'm gonna jump
here make it a little bigger so it the
important stuff is easier to see and if
you notice the binding energy of iron 55
there's quite a bit of it it's very well
bound in fact this is one of the most
well bound nuclei in the whole chart of
nuclides let's look at something that we
know to be particularly unstable someone
have any idea let's just add like 20
neutrons to iron let's see if it even
exists no doesn't happen let's try
adding 10 neutrons to iron go even
crazier
what about 70 to small all right let's
meet somewhere in the middle
68 still a pretty high binding energy
but you can look at it as a difference
in binding energy per nucleon so in this
case the binding energy per nucleon if
you take the binding energy and divided
by the total number of nucleons will
give you a relative measure of how
tightly bound that nucleus is now these
are not absolute things you can't just
say certain binding energy leads to
certain stability but they do give you
pretty good trends to follow and we're
actually going to be coming up with
probably on Thursday a semi empirical
formula to
get the rough binding energy of any
particular assembly of protons and
neutrons and it follows experimental
calc calculations pretty well
surprisingly so I want to jump back to
here because I've mentioned
cross-sections and I want to actually
define what a cross-section is because
this is a quantity that you're going to
be using everywhere let's say that we
fired a beam of particles it doesn't
matter what it is at a target of other
particles let's say that the beam
particles are atom a and the target
particles are atom B and once these a
particles pass through the target B a
little bit fewer of them come out the
other side unreacted or unscathed or unn
scattered and some of them are absorbed
or scattered or bounced off or scattered
backwards or what have you we can write
the sort of proportionality constant
between the change in intensity of our a
beam and the thickness of our slab and
we give that proportionality constant
this symbol little Sigma I'll get
something going up here little Sigma
which we call the microscopic cross
section it's in effect a constant of
proportionality that relates the
probability of absorbing an atom from
this beam i from this beam of atoms a
threw a slab of B and then if you take
this formula you divide by that Delta X
so I'm going to take what's on there and
say Delta I over Delta x equals minus
cross section a B n which refers here to
the number density so I'll keep our
table of symbols all together so it's a
little easier to follow and as our
number density which means the number of
atoms per unit volume usually in nuclear
quantities we use centimeters because
these are things that are actually
fairly measurable and cross-sections are
actually in you
it's of centimeters squared and let me
finish that expression we had the number
density of our target B we had our
initial intensity and that's it anyone
know how to solve this differential
equation if we take the limit of small
deltas should start to look like a
differential equation the final answer
is up there on the screen was anyone
remember the method to actually solve
this differential equation this is the
easy one separate the variables so in
this case we can divide each side by I
of X multiply each side by X I'm going
to bring this up so I'm not bending down
so we have di over I equals minus Sigma
a B and of B times DX integrate both
sides and we get log of I equals minus
Sigma a B and of B X and some
integration constant you can apply an
initial boundary condition to say that
it's equals 0 the intensity of the beam
X was some intensity I not whatever
intensity of the beam that we initially
fired at the target and by combining
these two you end up with the expression
you get right there which is that the
intensity of the beam coming out is the
initial intensity times e to the minus
Sigma a b-and-b X and we've kind of
derived the idea of exponential
attenuation for those who haven't seen
that word before attenuation or the
gradual removal of the beam of incident
particles by whatever the target happens
to be this quantity right here we
actually have another symbol for
which ah which we give big Sigma and in
this case big Sigma we call the
macroscopic cross-section I'll draw a
box around these so we know these are
our symbols that were keeping defined
here and so you may see that the
microscopic cross-section just depends
on single reactions between the incoming
atoms a and the target atoms be the
macroscopic cross-section depends on how
much B is there so if you want to get
per atom probabilities of absorption
scattering whatever thing you're looking
at you use the microscopic cross-section
and if you have a finite amount of stuff
there and you know the number density of
your substance B you can use the macro
macroscopic cross section to get actual
total probabilities of beam attenuation
or to calculate exponential attenuation
we're gonna see this again in another
form when we talk about designing
shielding and how much shielding do you
need to remove how much of the beam well
this quantity right here there's
actually tabulated values for a lot of
this stuff at on the NIST website and I
have links to that as well on the
stellar website so that you can instead
of having to look these all up on janus
and multiply number densities there are
some easier graphical functions you can
just find the value for but we'll get
back to that in a few days so anyway on
reading the Kairi table there's a few
quantities right there I we've already
defined what the excess mass and the
binding energy is and I want to note
right here if you want to actually
calculate binding energies by hand which
I'm going to ask you to do a bit on
problem set two you'll need to know what
the mass of the proton and the neutron
and the electron are to again usually
like six or seven digits is the is the
idea behind this course notice that
they're not exactly one atomic mass unit
because one atomic mass unit again was
set with that carbon-12 standard I'm not
going to use the word gold standard
because that's a misnomer in this field
and so like I said what does excess mass
really mean physically not much because
it's the comparison to an arbitrary
standard or a rather poor approximation
of the mass the binding energy actually
does represent the conversion of math to
energy when you assemble a nucleus like
Voltron style from its constituent
nucleons so let's try a few examples in
class right here I'd like you guys to
follow around and try and calculate the
binding energy of each of these three
nuclei of sulfur let me get a better
blank board you can follow along and
there's a few different ways of
calculating that binding energy you can
do it by the excess mass you can do it
by let's go back to the table of
nuclides so I can show you how I would
do it let's start with sulfur 32 and
we'll write up the quantities that were
that we know let's say the excess mass
is the actual mass minus the mass number
the binding energy is Z times mass of
hydrogen plus a minus Z mass of a
neutron minus the actual mass of that
nucleus with a Z Z squared and then what
we can do is rearrange this excess mass
isolating the mass term right here and
make a substitution so we can say the
mass is actually the excess mass plus a
stick that in right there and now we can
calculate and confirm the binding
energies that we see right here from
tabulated excess mass values atomic
number mass number and the masses of a
hydrogen atom and a neutron which for
reference all right up here as well so
the mass of a hydrogen is the mass of a
proton plus an electron so one point
zero seven two
oh seven - seven six plus point
Oh Oh Oh make that a little easier to
read how many zeros ooo five four eight
five eight am you massive a neutron
surprisingly close to Chadwicks
prediction eight six six four amu so now
I'll head back to the table of nuclides
and let's see if you guys can follow
along what we want to do is try to
confirm this binding energy using the
atomic mass the excess mass or if we
don't even know the atomic mass we can
use the excess mass plus a right there
so let's see Z in this case for sulphur
is 16 times the mass of hydrogen this is
definitely a calculator moment because
like I said I don't know about you guys
but I can't do eight significant digits
in my head oh five four eight five eight
one point zero seven eight two fives
probably enough digits plus sixteen
because there's mass number here is 32
the atomic number 16 that leaves us with
16 neutrons times the mass of a neutron
Oh 8 6 6 4 minus the excess mass which
in this case is 26 point oh one 5 MeV
oh one 5 MeV / C squared so thanks to
that same Garrett for that question
because indeed the excess mass if you
want to write it in terms of a mass
should be in MeV or ke V / C squared
minus a which is 32 times C squared
so let's do all this out shouldn't take
too long oh seven eight to five that's
one point oh eight six six four - 32 -
twenty six point zero one five divided
by C squared it's basically nothing
gives us on the order of let's see times
C squared
where do we get right here
let's see believe it is because we have
to subtract the mass and we're
substituting in this Delta oh good point
there is a negative there so that's
minus negative that and a is 32 thank
you yeah good point let me try this
again
ah I know what I'm doing wrong this part
right here we want to convert to amu
so we can take our - thank you twenty
six point oh one five MeV per C squared
and divided by our conversion factor
nine thirty one point four nine
it's the MeV per C squared per amu what
does that give us twenty six point oh
one five over that 0.027 9:00 to 8:00
a.m. you- let's put that in and see how
we do
so plus 0.02 798 minus 32 and then we
get to 71 point I'll just say 764 MeV I
think six digits is enough the actual
binding energy to 70 1.78 Oh MeV so
we're off by 16 electron volts close
enough
also note that I used a five digit
accurate conversion factor that might be
part of the source of it someone have a
question
oh yeah I actually added the two so the
mass of an electron since it's got that
extra zero makes so much of a so the
mass of oh yeah a massive hydrogen would
be the proton plus the electron right
there oh because it's there's an
electron there too now this can usually
be neglected because it's such small
fraction compared to everything else so
now we're talking about what the fifth
or sixth decimal place but just for
exactness I could stuck them in yeah in
your calculation you can try with and
without and I think you'll find that it
doesn't matter that much because in the
end we get the binding energy that we
see on the table to within 16 electron
volts for a total of yeah 271 MeV that's
pretty accurate
yeah that's the next slide I'll get
right there yeah so you hear you're
catching on to where we're going so once
you can calculate either the excess mass
or the binding energy or the total mass
of any nucleus you can start to put them
together into nuclear reactions so since
you asked let's take a quick look at
them where is our nuclear reaction board
anyone mind if I hide this board for now
so we can go back to our original okay
let's take a look at this reaction right
here the actual boron Neutron capture
therapy reaction and now we can get
towards calculating this Q what the
difference is between the energies of
total energies of the products and the
reactants and where does that go so now
we can either look up or calculate the
binding energy of each of these nuclei
subtract off the energy of the gamma
which I've looked up already is about
0.478 MeV and we can figure out what the
total Q of this reaction is so in this
case I'll skip ahead to the slide where
I've got it because that way all right
anything wrong
the board got everything right up here
we assume that both boron and the
neutron have roughly zero kinetic energy
and at the end they come out with some
other kinetic energies as well as this
gamma ray the sum of this energy
difference as we refer to as Q and we
can actually confirm this total Q with a
few different methods in this case it's
always conserved something that's the
the whole theme of this course that you
can conserve total masses you can
conserve total kinetic energies we may
not know those but tabulated in the in
the Kairi table are the binding energies
of each of these nuclei so let's try
that out right now so let's look at the
binding energies of each of these nuclei
and see what the difference is the total
energy released first of all what's the
binding energy of a lone Neutron anyone
have any idea see a lot of these zero
yeah you haven't assembled the nucleus
out of a lone Neutron so we'll go with
the neutron has a binding energy of zero
MeV boron not quite the case but we can
go back to the table of nuclides and
punch that in boron 10 we can look up
its binding energy which is about sixty
four point seven 507 I keep saying about
which is exactly 64 point 7 507 MeV and
then our other two nuclei helium-4 so
you can punch in helium four here it's
got a binding energy of exactly 28 point
two nine five 673 MeV and finally
lithium seven
let's punch that in think you guys are
gonna get very familiar with this table
there's a few versions out there there's
a new slick Java version that I found a
little hard to use so I like the
text-only version because it's just as
simple and fast as it gets thirty nine
point two four four five to six five to
six so any sort of increase in total
amount of binding energy between the
reactants and the products
is going to release or absorb energy now
because boron does capture a thermal
Neutron or a neutron with approximately
zero evie of kinetic energy does anyone
have any idea whether this would release
or consume energy in other words you
think this is an exothermic or an
endothermic reaction
yeah Alex okay indeed if the total Q
value is greater than zero we refer to
this as exothermic kind of like in
chemistry and if Q is less than zero we
refer to this as endothermic so let's do
our binding energy subtraction now we
want to figure out how much excess
binding energy is released so I'm going
to take the reactants I'm sorry I'm
gonna take the products so helium two
nine five six seven three add lithium 2
4 4 5 2 6 subtract boron seven 507
subtract the neutron which is zero and
we're left with two point seven nine MeV
and because it's positive this is an
exothermic reaction which is what we'd
expect because this reaction actually
happens if this was an endothermic
reaction what could you do to make it
occur
yeah like with temperature or what do
you mean there you go
so actually yeah you kind of said the
same thing twice heating things up does
give them higher kinetic energy if you
rely on temperature you'll be imparting
Evi worth of kinetic energy but if you
accelerate them or get them from a
different nuclear reaction and you get
them up to the MeV level where whatever
this Q value could be might be negative
then you can get the reaction to occur
for example what is the Q of that
reaction
negative that so in this case if you
want lithium to absorb an alpha particle
and make boron and a neutron you would
have to accelerate the alphas to that
same amount of energy in order to get
this to occur
so nuclear reactions do go both ways
just not as easily kind of like chemical
reactions you can drive them in
different directions by changing the
temperature changing the concentration
of the reactants here the concentration
doesn't matter but the kinetic energy
related directly to the temperature
definitely is and so in this case it's
2.79 MeV if I tell you the gamma ray
takes off 0.478 MeV of that we're left
with two point three one MeV between the
lithium nucleus and the helium nucleus
now my next question of my last question
for you today oh man is what's the split
I think I don't want to keep you longer
because it's one minute of 10 so this is
the question that we're gonna pick up
with on Thursday which is how much of
the energy is taken off by helium and
how much is taken off by lithium sorry I
should have kept better track of the
time
you